Hi.
As you can see, I put up there
Science in the Media, Fitting
a Square Peg in a Round Hole.
And as I talk, I hope it
will become obvious
why I'm saying that.
So, the journey, where
are we going to go?
We're going to look at who the
main players are when we talk
about science in the media.
How does the media work?
How does science work?
A bit of a think about why we
need science coverage in the
first place, criticisms of
science in the media,
alternatives to where we are at
the moment, how things are
changing, and who controls
what science
appears in the media.
And then: the future, how on
earth are we going to fund
continued science
in the media?
So, the main players,
who have we got?
We've got the scientists.
They do the science that
the media report on.
You've then got scientific
bodies, places like the Ri.
You've got government.
They might fund science, develop
science policy, put on
events just like this
that then create
coverage in the media.
You then have press offices.
They sit between the science
and the journalists.
They kind of interpret what the
scientists are doing and
sell it to the media, and that's
a job that I've had.
That's been one of my main jobs,
is doing that job in the
middle there.
And at the end of the day, key
to the media, at the heart of
the media, are the journalists,
and they're the
ones who actually do the job of
reporting on the science,
interviewing the
scientists, and
presenting it to the public.
OK, so the media - what's
the media all about?
Short time scale, simple
messages, clear-cut yes or no
answers, focus on disagreement
and exceptions at its basis.
Science: long time scale,
complicated messages, no hard
and fast answers, and it
works on consensus.
So already you can see
it's quite different.
What the media wants, it's
very different from how
science works.
They're kind of at
opposite poles.
So are they completely
incompatible?
And Quentin Cooper, who presents
Material World on BBC
Radio 4, I just thought this
was a really nice quote.
He was saying to me, science
values detail, precision, the
impersonal, the technical, the
lasting, facts, numbers, and
being right.
Journalism values brevity,
approximation, the personal,
the colloquial, the immediate,
stories, words,
and being right now.
And there are going
to be tensions.
But can we overcome
these tensions?
And you can see there's a
completely blank slide there,
because I was starting to think
about why do we need
science media coverage
in the first place?
Why do we need science out
there on TV, in the
newspapers, on the internet?
And I originally had put down
a number of points as to why
we might need it, but I suddenly
thought, actually
that's something that you should
be thinking about, is
what is the purpose of it?
If it's so diametrically
opposed, why do we need it in
the first place?
And just listening to Hugh
was making me think.
Already I can think of a
thousand reasons how we'd know
about all the stuff that Hugh
was talking about if it wasn't
for the media.
But anyway, I left that one
blank rather than giving you
all the answers, because I
thought that was my job.
So, criticisms of science
coverage.
And it does come under quite
a deal of criticism,
particularly from scientists
themselves.
They would say that the coverage
distorts the facts,
is quite arbitrary.
What ends up in the newspapers
isn't really representative of
what's going on out in
the world of science.
Kill or cure sensationalism, and
we've all seen this kind
of thing where one day chocolate
is good for you, the
next day it gives you cancer.
You know, it's the same things
do one thing one day,
something the other day.
Dumbing down: the science is
made so simple as to actually
making it wrong.
In the end it's just
completely wrong.
And perpetuating the idea of
novelty and breakthrough.
So the way it's reported is that
science just happens in
these small bursts of we know
this, we know this, we now
know this, when in fact that
isn't how science works.
It's a much more
gradual process
of coming to consensus.
So, also criticism of science
journalists and what they do.
There's big criticism about
false conflict, dressing it up
as balance.
So if we take the example of
the environment, climate
change, you put two people up
against each other, somebody
who says yeah, climate change
is all down to humans, and
then somebody who says actually
no, it was nothing to
do with us.
Vast consensus of opinion on one
side, tiny minority on the
other, but put up against each
other as though they're yes or
no in the same way they might
do with politicians.
That kind of model doesn't
really work for science.
Pack journalism, where science
journalists all
cover the same story.
If you look in the papers today,
if there's a science
story, it'll be in all the
papers, it'll be on the news.
They're all covering
the same stuff.
They're not digging up
their own stories.
Which is where we come to
churnalism, which is a great
term for journalists just
churning out stories.
They get the press release,
they just completely
regurgitate it.
They don't even ring up to
get their own quotes.
They don't even dig
a bit deeper.
They don't see if there's
anybody who's saying, hang on
a minute, this isn't
quite right.
They churn it out.
And so at the end of the
day, people say science
journalists, they're no longer
being journalists.
Now what does this all matter?
My son was quite concerned that
wouldn't be big enough.
I think that's quite big.
It's a cartoon from
the States, but I
just quite liked it.
You start out with
these scientists.
Here he is saying, oh, A is
correlated with B, given C,
assuming D, under
E conditions.
So there's a bit of a
relationship between A and B,
but there's all these
little caveats.
But then it goes to
the press office.
They put out a press
release about it.
They're quite good about it,
because they say they find a
potential link in there under
certain conditions.
By the time it gets into the
news, onto the internet, A
causes B, then A causes
B all the time.
What will this mean for Obama?
Sorry, this is an
American slide.
Then it gets onto
the local news.
What you don't know about
A can kill you.
A: the killer amongst us.
At the end of the day, your
grandma comes back to you as a
scientist, saying, I'm wearing
this hat to ward off A. So you
can see how something that
starts out quite measured goes
through the cycle and comes out
black and white: A causes
B.
So what?
So what does this really matter
if it's not completely
accurate, if the media kind of
misinterpret it to fit into
their model?
Well at worst, you can have
serious consequences for
public health.
The example of MMR where there
were a number of reports all
about the fact that the
MMR vaccination
would lead to autism.
And there was in the end a big
drop in the number of children
having the vaccination, a rise
in the number of measles
cases, and it did have
an effect on health.
So that is quite a
serious effect.
But what about non-health
stories, stories about physics
or chemistry, for example?
Does it really matter if the
public don't understand the
full nitty-gritty of scientific
research, and if
it's all slightly wrong?
And is it the job of the media
to be educating the
public in any case?
Is that really their role?
Now what's an alternative
scenario?
And this is something that's
happening at the moment,
scientists going out there,
talking direct to the public
via blogs, via podcasts - the
opportunities the internet has
given to us.
And scientific bodies doing
exactly the same thing, they
create their own news, so they
produce their own news about
their own work.
And this is already,
as I say, happening
here and in the States.
But think about this.
Isn't that just self-serving
publicity by organisations
with their own agenda to promote
what they're doing?
What best serves the
public interest?
Are we better served by
journalists doing the job of
journalism, investigating,
criticising, getting to the
truth, or by scientists and
scientific institutions
telling their own story?
So hearing it from the
horse's mouth.
Also another thing
to think about.
Who controls what appears
in the media?
The stories that are out there
today, who is actually sort of
making sure some story's
there, and some aren't?
Is it the media itself, or is it
the science establishment?
And who serves the public
interest better - if the
scientists are in control or
if the media in control?
Now there's been a bit of a
shift here over the years, and
it used to be very much the
media were the gatekeepers of
the science that ended
up out there.
But now because - there's
a number of
issues I've put here.
There's probably all
sorts of different
factors involved in this.
Multi-platform coverage -
journalists used to just have
to write a story.
They now write the story, they
have to blog on it, they have
to do a video, they have to sing
the theme tune, write the
theme tune.
There's just so much more
for them to do.
They don't have time to go out
there, find their own stories.
So because of that, the
science PR people, the
scientists, the scientific
organisations, they hold much
more power.
They put out the information
there.
The journalists as we said, they
just regurgitate it, that
churnalism effect.
So the power more in the hands
of the science establishment -
good or bad?
And at the end of the day, the
biggest challenge, it all
comes down to money, which
most of these things do.
And one of the biggest
challenges facing the media is
how we're going to fund
journalism into the future
when everything is
readily available
for free on the internet.
So how are we going
to fund it?
And the first to go when there
will be cutbacks are the
specialist journalists, the
specialists being the science
journalists.
So at the end of the day, how
might we fund those science
journalists if in fact
you feel that we
still do need them?
Or is it better that we just
hear everything straight from
scientists?
So we're getting something
to think about.
Anyway, a bit of a whistle stop
tour, and more questions
than answers, but that's
what I was told to do.
So I hope that's given you
some food for thought.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]